[Music]
welcome back to Rich Eisen show please
have right here for the very first time
my colleague from the NFL Network who
travels the country to host Thursday
Night Football for the network and the
media group every single Thursday night
and also Saturdays on Good Morning
football and OSHA also on Mondays on NFL
total axis good to see you Colleen wolf
great to be here this is a fun maiden
voyage this is a fun maiden voyage yeah
yes and we take a three-hour tour here
every single day
that's awesome pleased that you are here
so let's get let's get right into it
you've heard our our conundrum that we
have set up here there are worse things
this is a high-class problem being a
fantasy football defending champ the
concept of changing your team after
having won a fantasy championship is
good or bad what do you think well I
think if you're a team that changes your
name every year yes then maybe you got
to stick with that like don't maybe
change it up just because you won but if
this if you're a team that has had this
name for a couple years now like you got
to stick with it well we have a
one-and-done we've been a different team
name every yes okay so it's so it's
consistent yeah the inconsistency is
consistent I think that because the
championship now you have the option of
keeping it because it's a championship
yes team name right but me personally I
would just I keep doing what you've been
doing okay so I think I think we do go
manspreading
is it manspreading or men's spread man
spread masterpiece spread centerpiece
man spread masterpiece Andy redeem and
spread centerpiece centerpiece because
we are friendly center of this league
rich we are number one
we are the centerpiece of this league
I'm saying I think Andy would be
thrilled about this too don't you think
yeah I think he'd be really happy I
think wait till we have him on the show
and tell him what we're doing hey listen
man nobody a man spreads quite like Andy
Reid you know t-shirts everything all
sorts of merged I think oh look at how
Sebring gives him all of the merch to of
himself I don't know about that why not
because it's our idea well I mean he's
the one who did man spread he's the one
who did put it all
out there he's the pioneer he is the
George Washington just think about that
you sit down and you're like okay I've
got all my colleagues no no previous one
yeah it's kind of different innit
our previous one was touch of the
Vermeil which is well well it's well
begin to get misty when you begin to cry
whenever we get emotional we get a touch
of the Vermeil I know one we won it all
we had a whole bracket challenge last
year and Paul Rudd decided yes team name
was well I mean if you're gonna go for a
meal and he's a cheese I mean he went it
was that was the end of that all right
it's it man spread centerpiece done is
gonna be showing up Jerry Cantrell's
house today like two and a half hours of
Vinnie Paul trophy we're just gonna
throw that thing right down there and
we're say with come at it got the
winning pedigree I think it's great now
you have the name what is your what is
your dirty name again so I have Wolf
Blitzer okay and I have raised by wolves
so I have a crazy picture of my dad
partying okay yeah so it's it's usually
a wolf is that you've got a tie tied
around his head and sunglasses on at a
bar dancing
Colleen hungry like the wolf yeah great
I'm in three leagues this year so that's
gonna be my third hungry like the wolf
who was a factor and I'm always hungry
so what's so that would be the avatar
would be Duran Duran yes you'd have to
take the album cover from actually the
single cover hung like the wolf and put
that as he's got you set I got some
homework
situated thanks colleen wolf from NFL
Network right here on the Rich Eisen
show you were gonna be on an absurd
amount of plane flights this year I know
so your first week Buccaneers at
Panthers that's a pretty damn big one
right there yeah right off the bat as a
matter of fact I think we've got the the
second version of that is going to be
the London game one of the ones it's
it's like what five weeks yeah five
weeks later yeah week six London game is
gonna be Panthers and Bucks as well and
are you guys all gonna be in the booth
again yeah it looks like it's gonna be
four men in a booth
so fun I know that for me Irv and mooch
and Curt but you're gonna be Bucks and
Panthers first up and then Titans
Jaguars is week number three for
Thursday Night Football and then then
the big one I know you're from Philly so
you know you know what this Eagles
Packers game is gonna be this is this is
the one that I have circled on my
calendar I bet I've never been to
Lambeau and I've always wanted to go
this is like a bucket list stadium for
me and then when the schedule came out
and I saw that we're going to Lambeau
and the Packers are playing the Eagles I
mean that's fantastic bringing family
members they're gonna be either stuff
like that or what I maybe uh I know I
know you're there for to do a job right
right my my husband's gonna come to the
Seattle game and the San Francisco or
the Oakland game but I might see if I
can get mr. wolf to come out to Lambeau
okay that would be fun it's the amount
of Philadelphia hopes and wishes about
Carson Wentz are through the roof we had
our compadre Daniel Jeremiah here a
couple weeks ago he thinks that he's the
MVP for the NFL season is consequence
and did in fact say that he thinks that
he is really it I know right so what do
you think of the Eagles chances this
year so well of course I'm so as
somebody from Philadelphia and I don't
know I can't speak for everybody
obviously but I always kind of set the
bar really low and then that way I'm
never disappointed but now after they
won the Super Bowl and this team it
looks really good and I start to
question myself because I'm not setting
the bar low anymore right I think I
think they're going to be good I think
they can win the division and I think
they can really compete in the NFC
they're top to bottom their roster is
stacked and they have a lot of guys that
are coming back from injury like
Fletcher Cox even their offensive line
which by the way did you see that there
yes yeah they're in the body issue I
know I know that is pretty amazing and
this kid Myles Sanders um he's kind of
the wild card here yeah I know they got
Jordan Howard from the Bears I really
want to know what this kid is gonna look
like because
he could be dynamic and somebody that
kind of brings I I guess I don't want to
box anybody in but sort of what tarik
Cohen brings to Chicago bringing that to
this Philadelphia system even needed
somebody like that to fit that mold and
they just haven't had it controls can't
stay healthy right and so now they have
him and look he went to Penn State was
the backup to say Quan right he didn't
get a ton of work because of that and so
I think that he's gonna surprise a lot
of people because I think he kind of
flew under the radar a little bit right
and I can't wait to see him mm-hmm I
know and so him and say Quan in the same
division it's just kind of fun I know it
so let me ask you this what would have
happened if Wentz retired okay and
Philly fans booed him off the field what
are you you don't have saying like what
we're hearing about what Colts fans have
done and they Colts fans have received a
requisite amount of grief there's no
question for that but what would it have
been like if Philly fans had done that
that would just go right up on the shelf
next to booing Santa Claus and throwing
batteries at people I mean that's what
Philly fans do but also it's like yeah I
think that Philly fans get such a bad
rap and anytime they do something it is
just blown up out of proportion because
people love to hate on Eagles fans in
particular I think yes they're they are
a tough group but look when I think
Colts fans do it it's not received as
it's not received the same way that
equals fans if they did it it would I
know the intensity would have been
through the roof yes I know and it for
years we would never hear the end of it
it would just be that that same story
over and over and over again we had a
third Thursday night game in Philly when
Andy Reid came back oh and it was
dynamite fans were great really yes and
then now we were there the night also
that McNabb got
sent off and there there was no there
was no animosity Andy Reid came back it
was really just a nice night actually
Andy Reid has a special place in Eagles
fans hearts and even though he left and
now teaches or coaches hunt teaches a
different team it's it's different he I
don't think that he's looked at as an
enemy I think in Philadelphia there are
people that are hated and loved and
because of what Andy did it's like he
gets special dispensation when he comes
back and I think the same will be for
Nick Foles because forever he's going to
have a piece of our heart yeah and you
see Nick Foles right away week three I
mean the Jaguars are a fascinating team
to me because I have no idea what Falls
gonna look like for net there is a great
did you see the bleacher report article
that came out today Brockman and I know
that that's part of our where he said
he's gonna be in the top five for net
says that he is cut people out of his
life okay that were holding him back and
that he's a changed man because he was
effing tired of losing Wow and if he can
stay healthy and if he's the guy that
that can in year three run downhill and
hit you and stay healthy and foals can
do what he's didn't done and
Philadelphia and that defense is ready
to go yeah you have to wonder which
folds we're gonna see though so there
has always been to different Nick Foles
so even when he had come back and played
early in the season for the Eagles I
can't remember if it was last year or
the year before maybe it was last year
he didn't look that great he looked a
little shaky right and then he came back
as the team was making their push and
then in the playoffs obviously he's a
totally different player I mean he just
elevates everybody around him so if he
can do that in Jacksonville now I just
wonder because do they have a guy that
he he really likes foals does big-bodied
receivers like and all Shaun like Zach
Ertz like just big past catchers does he
have that and does he have the offensive
line to do what he needs to do in
Jacksonville well they had no offensive
line last year
I mean I remember again they played the
London game they're gonna play none of
them interesting enough we have to
London games on the NFL Network and and
and they're gonna be playing again
they're taking on the Texans this year
that when they were showed up to London
literally half the offensive line they
left home and then the defensive backs
they wanted to send them home because
they stayed out too late send them home
because they needed them to play I mean
last year was a total disaster for
Jacksonville
unmitigated disaster with fournette
getting suspended because he fought in
Buffalo lost his mind than didn't show
up a couple of times on time and it was
a disaster and if they hit the reset
button and foals can bring something I
mean obviously many people think the
division is now wide open up for grabs
because of what happened with luck I
know which came out of nowhere but it's
sort of like if Jacksonville just has a
serviceable quarterback even if nick
foles isn't at that level that he was at
at the end of the season with the Eagles
that Super Bowl season the the crazy
year worry through like two picks and
that was it even if he is just like an
average quarterback I think they have a
shot few more minutes left here with
Colleen Wolfe host of NFL Network's
Thursday Night Football coverage here
summary great and and I have personal
memories of having done the job for
years on Thursday night in these places
Rams at Seahawks is week five how about
that Brockman Rams at Seahawks week five
monster and we did it I think it was
Rams at Seahawks where it ring rings so
hard that the game Bobby 40 it was 49ers
Seahawks cuz Alex Smith lit it up once
we started playing they delayed the game
because the turf bubbled up turf bubbled
up it rains so damn hard there was also
in another Thursday night game where we
it was the beginning of the Marshawn era
in Seattle and they rained skittles on
our set post we had Colleen it was funny
this was before the year before Russell
arrived and we invited because Marshawn
wasn't coming to talk we invited Pete
Carril be
there was nobody else that was amazing
well there was nobody else that would be
you know they had no brand right but
there was nobody there's no identity
right there was no identity and we asked
pika what's the identity of this team
that was like the main part of our
conversation
Giants Patriots holy smokes
and that's week six so who knows what
Giants team you're gonna see one maybe
it's gonna be Daniel Jones I don't know
but that all I know is that that's gonna
begin to boil week six is when they
might have no patience for Eli or Eli
and the Giants have been surprisingly
good and here they come as the
Kryptonite I wonder when the Giants buy
is that information so late week 11 we
also did a Thursday night game Jets
Patriots that was the year that Brady
was hurt it was Brett Favre are and the
man genius went in in overtime
Castle beat castle and and we're set to
go on the air and Randy Moss caught the
game-tying touchdown directly in front
of me and mooch in all of us and then
the Minutemen fired off their guns be
careful if you first oh my god we got
scared I'd literally I think I did do
something in my pants
it was so and then over time happens
Favre we're trying to get Favre on the
set he's on the podium doing the
postgame press conference mooch texted
him hey are you coming by afterwards and
the phone buzzed right in the middle of
his press conference from mooches Texas
awesome what a flex that is that was
amazing strong
Chiefs Broncos week seven hmm I love
going to Denver I've never that's
another one that's another one of the
stadiums that I've never been to and I
get to check it off the list and I'm so
excited about that yeah we did it we did
a child our memory like we did a
Chargers Broncos Thursday night game
recently was when we were done with it
was a Peyton's final I think it was a
final year and Phillip went in and beat
the Broncos stunned them in week 15 it
closed on the Thursday night football
schedule he showed up in ostrich boots
like these best bollo times I and
ostrich boots and he was just like a
five-year-old
shot out of a cannon everyone was
talking about how great he was in the
postgame show so we said hey get a shot
of his boots and they zoomed in on the
boots and also caught the cheerleader
calendar that cheerleaders that he put
right down underneath
[Laughter]
what does Philip Rivers this closet look
like with all sorts of boots or well
it's probably all sorts of maybe he has
a separate closet just for his bolo ties
like that yeah but it's funny you
mentioned that because last year when
the Chargers beat the Chiefs at the end
of the season last minute what a
Thursday night game Allen yes yes it was
you know the Chargers they never win at
Arrowhead and it had playoff
implications and last-second touchdown
to win the game and Philip Rivers same
thing he came on the set and he was so
animated he just lit up and I was like
let's just let's just keep going let's
just see how long we can talk with him
for because he was just telling us
everything and anything and was just on
fire and you were in the room for the
NFL media group symposium when al River
on the head of NFL refs walked us
through pass interference saying oh by
the way that pass interference penalty
that set the Chargers up on the one-yard
line
leading to the same play back to back to
Mike Williams to score the touchdown and
then the cojones to go for two with the
same play and when the game would never
have happened because under further
review there would have been offsetting
penalties on that defensive pass
interference they would have caught Mike
Williams pushing off on all that does
that make you terribly sad that's not
the reason why this this this deal we
didn't we didn't sign up for that no
that was one of my favorite games was
one of my favorite Thursday games of the
year maybe any game of the year but I
mean last year the Browns and Jets when
the Browns won and Baker Mayfield came
in for the first he was a hell of a
season Derrick Henry went off on a
Thursday night it was in a remarkable
Thursday night season last year and you
know it's because you did it instead of
me oh I mean all those i sat there i sat
there and all these blowouts oh my god
and then just late before I let you go
the late games that I hope mean
something Steelers at Browns week 11
holy crap
if that means something right that will
be so about this one a division Colts at
Texans week 12 that's the week before
Thanksgiving hey you know it could I
think Jacoby Brissette is going to be
terrific yes I think he is not gonna
obviously it's not luck
but I think he's gonna he is gonna keep
this team in contention if not win the
division yeah remember two years ago
when he was playing when Luck was out
and he was he had some great throws he
was playing well and remember he was
playing behind an offensive line that
was a complete disaster and since that
time they've revamped the entire line
Cowboys at bears is the now that we've
been doing this for many years two teams
that play on Thanksgiving play on
Thursday night the following
Thanksgiving so it's a full complement
of rest it's not a short week for either
team and that's gonna be amazing Cowboys
at bears in Chicago I hope for your sake
that is some of the coldest Thursday
nights I've ever experienced oh I'm I'm
just gonna you will only see my eyes
okay and then the last one the Thursday
night football season wraps up jets at
Ravens could mean if that means
something to left Bell versus the Ravens
by the way and then I am so high on
Lamar Jackson are you oh yeah
I am the Lamar Jackson fan base and the
sole one I think
Brockman you just leave me alone on this
one I think he's gonna be terrific
yeah do you think do you think we'll see
more from his arm I think we will see
more from his arm and his legs and I
think we're gonna see a better running
game yeah cuz Ingram's here now and I
think we're gonna see some unique
wrinkles using trace McSorely nobody's
seen coming oh and I can't wait to see
Hollywood Brown take the top of the
defense off and I can't wait to see all
these tight ends that they have I think
that they are lying in wait for
everybody that thinks the Browns and the
Steelers and etc is so good he's so fast
and he was hurt during the combine I
think that a lot of people didn't really
think that much about it seeing him at
all there's so many different things
that we haven't seen in just by
including Myles Sanders like I said we
have not seen
a lot and I can't wait for it all to
start and it starts one week from
tonight in Green Bay and then after that
Thursday Night Football on and if I'm
network in Fox Bucs and Panthers Titans
and Jaguars good to see you calling wolf
thanks for having me anytime you got it
travel safe thank you you got it if you
need any TV show tips we've got we got
some help for you two very good at
colleen wolf with a silent e at the end
on twitter and instagram right here on
the Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app